Hello everybody! My Name is Markipiler and welcome to Eternal Walk.
Now, I found this game on Itch.io and it seemed interesting,
judging by the face in front of me and the spazzing out name
but who knows once we get into it.
It might be crap, it might be great.
Oh good! The typical controls on every game ever made.
"Watch your back, sometimes the shadows can stalk you..."
"Run if the ambiance becomes creepy."
"When you finish your goal, go back to the entrance at the beginning."
OKAY, seems good enough!
Markbob Squarestache: I'm ready!
I don't know why we're doing- oo... enter?
*In-game thumping*
What the fuck?
Yes?
*thumping continues*
Whu- OH!
[warning for headphone users- this game will blow off your ears.]
OH! What the fuck?
Woooah, where am I?
*strange stepping noises, like the character might have a prosthetic leg*
Ok, this is a little bizarre...
I had no idea this was what it was gonna be like...
Hello?
It's been a long time since I played an indie horror game like this...
Y'know, one that kinda drops you into a narrow corridor, kinda dungeon style thing...
With no real explanation?
And just some, uuh... intresting-
Ooo, hey.
Hello!
Oh, hi.
How you doin'?
I got a cassete!
Why am I getting a cassete?
For what purpose is this happen?
Is this a Slender sim- oooh, God.
Yeah, that's not just me, that's the walls shakin'.
Why are the walls shakin'?
okay.
Y'know, when you drop me into a pot like this, and you don't explain anything,
two things can happen.
And- it can either be really stupid or suddenly very creepy.
And this kinda took that latter route.
*softly* ok.
What did it say?
If the-
Oh, jeez.
Why are the walls shaking?
Why am I in here?
And- and why am I holding, like, a femur bone as my hand?
*softly* I don't even know.
I don't think I wanna know.
Can I run? I can run, okay.
*a very soft hum plays in the backround*
I hear somethin.
*loud bwang*
AH FUCK YOU!
HI! What the fuck was that?
Was that a thing?
What was that?
Is there something I actually need to be worried about, or is that just...
random occurrences.
Something tells me that was not random.
*soft* what the fuck?
Alrighty the- hello, open room!
That's a big change!
Okay!
How nice!
It's still bizarre, that this game is like, entirely played on the bottom part of the screen here.
I don't know how I'm gonna be able to find all the cassette-
Hello!
I found another cassette! *ironically*
WOOO!
GOOD FOR ME!
Do I get a prize?
IS THE PRIZE DEATH?
I think it's okay.
Alright.
Jeez.
*loud bwang*
AW FUCK!
*SCREAMING*
AAH FUCK YOU WHAT THE FUCK WAS THAT
OKAY! I SAW SOMETHING OUT OF THE CORNER OF- OOH GOD DAMMIT.
HI!
UUUuuum,
Thing that was just there?
You better not be there anymore.
*bwang, followed by screaming again* Aw, fuck off.
Uuugh, what was that? What was that?
Okay, now that I got better bearings about it, I dunno if it was actually anything.
And if I was just scared for-
*squelchy stab* *gasps*
*stands still in awe*
*secondary stab*
OOWIE!
OH, I thought I was dead! (no duh)
What the fuck?!
What the fuck is happening? I can't tell if this game is actually well made, or not well made,
And it's just buggin out an-
*loud screaming*
HI! Stop screamin at me!
There is no need!
Ooogh, there is no need.
I'm a nice guy, you can just ask me politely...
Ugh..
I- I don't- am I goin in circles here or-  what is it-
Oh, hey.
O- okay, I think that's another one, but I- I- I think I'm being stalked!
Uuuh.
Uugh.
Hello?
Is there someone here?
I can't excactly say it's using cheap jumpscares,
because I don't know why to-
*bwang + scream*
AA FUCK YOU!
*loud screaming*
WooOOOooaah!
WooOOoah!
*surprise stab!*
AH FUCKING-
OH GOD DAMMIT!
AH!
CAN'T SEE!
CAN'T SEE, HEADPHONE FELL OFF! CAN'T HEAR!
WOOAH, CAN'T DEAL WITH IT NOW, GOTTA RUN!!
What the fuck!
Holy...
POOP
Okay. I'm in the clear!
Oh, jeez.
*bwang*
AAAH!
*EXTREMELY LOUD SCREAMING*
IT'S FUCKING- WHAT THE FUCK!
God DAMMIT, MY HEADPHONES!
OOH, what happened to my HEAD!
Why is my head so lubricated that my headphones just, fly off??
*loud double screaming*
uUUuuugh!
I hear that, even not on my headphones on.
God dammit!
*loud screaming*
Ahh, fuck!
I can't stop, I can't stop, I'm in a crisis!
I dunno where I am!
I lost completely.
*loud screaming!*
oh, god, I have no idea what is happening anYMORE!
Uuuuh, why is that thing after me?
Ok, I- I don't know!
I don't know where I've been because I-
AAH FUCK OFF! wHAT THE FUCK! STOP SHOVIN ME! OOH GOD I'M FUCKED.
Ohhh, god DAMMIT!
What the fuck happened!
How was I supposed to avoid any of that!
Oh, jeez.
Oh, what the hell? Like, my sensitivity went way down all of a sudden...
Why that happen?
Yeah, suddenly my sensitivity on my... mouse is waaay lower than it was...
I'll give this one more try, but I dunno...
I dunno about this...
Alright, lemme just get this- Okay, I'm obviously back at the beginning
and I think I sort of understand that the hand...
The arm? Is a hand holding a latern.
At least, that's my understanding about it.
So I just gotta generally skedaddle along here
Find the few cassettes that I can and don't be cornered.
But it's kinda hard to... kinda hard to avoid when..
There's narrow corridors and the other things seem to be sprinting at me...
I don't like this.
I don't like this. But then again like I said before at the beginning of this,
I have not played a game like this in a long time.
Oh. I think there's actually one over here...
*sirens*
Hey. Hi.
*mark mimics the jumpscare.*
It's like why- *bwang* - ugh!
Like a high-pitched Waluigi screamin in my ear.
WWHEH!
UUGH!
HI!
That's Wario.
*loud screaming*
AAA FUCK YOU
Criminy christmas! Don't do that! What are you?
*stab* Uh! Hi! Okay!
*squelch* Your'e like impossible to avoid!
Fuck off with you! *buttstab* Oh you creepy, twitchy bastard!
Get outta here!
Aw, man.
Ok.
Man, that is weird.
Now that I'm- *AAA* Now that I'm getting used to it,
like, I can obviously see some of the... some of the faults of this game.
There it was again.
I saw like. Two circles.
Okay, he's gonna be comin at me.
*bwang* *mark making Waluigi noises*
Where is he? Where is he at?
Cmon! Come at me bro!!
What do you got! What do you got?
You got anything? You got nothin!
Okay. Where'd he go?
oh shit.
is he down this hallway?
No?
*bwang*
Op. I think so? Yes? Maybe? Hello?
Hi! I'm not gonna run smack into you, again, am I?
*yells* Fuck off. Okay.
I know where you are now!
Ya screamy bitch!
*loud screaming* OH, SHIT! FUCK YOU AND YOUR SPRINT!
FUCK OFF!
He's got a charge ability, but it's on a cooldown. He can't get me.
*distant yell*
*mark imitates Chica*
*marks rooos*
Raar I'm so lonely.
Okay, so this just leads back to the big open corridor area.
Yeah it does.
Imma see if there's, like, another way to go around here.
I don't think there is. Ah, there was! Okay!
So now that I got these cassettes, maybe I can get to the end of this,
But I highly doubt if I'm gonna be lost in this maze.
Oh, god dammit. Branching paaaths! Fuck me.
Op, there's another one. Got it!
nnGot it!
*loud jumpscare, you know the drill.*
Aaaah! Get outta my way! Get outta my way, buddy. Get out. Get out.
Push 'em outta the way.
I BOOSH ya outta the way!
*yellin*
WWHEEEEEH! Okay.
I dunno how much health I have left, but it can't be a lot.
*distant yell* He hit me a bunch.
AAAR!
*bwang, followed by dull, deep sirens*
WOAH x5 THATS NEW!
OKAY I DIDNT THINK THERE WAS GONNA BE ANYTHING NEW!
Ugh. What in the hell is that?
*deep sirens continue* Woah, where am I?
Oooh, I've entered the plain of nonexistence!
Aaaa, shit dude.
Uuuvent- uh.
The last guardian of the cassette tape, here.
There's gotta be a door, just along this wall here, I imagine.
Just along here..
*sirens stop*
There we go. Okay. Got it.
Okay, well that was fun!
That was an excursion. *stabby scream* Aw, fuck OFF, DUDE!
Jeezums!
Stop with your charge!
*yelllll* Fuck off! With you!
Oh, god dammit, I've got one more. Ugh, I'm not gonna make it.
They're gonna kill me. *sirens* Ugh, jeez, that thing.
AAAAAH! It's got me by the ankles!
Shit, I think I went a wrong way.
Yeah, I went a wrong wa- I'm fucked. God dammit!
AWWW, FUCK OFF I HAD ONE MORE LEF-
I'm not doin it again.
Okay! Okay! Alright! Okay!
I uh... I'm not gonna try to do that again.
Mostly because I was wandering there for quite a while, just trying to find it as it is!
Um and as I was playing along, like, it got me in the beginning,
and I'll give it full credit for that,
it got me in the beginning,
uh, but once I started to see more of the game, I saw the obvious flaws that were poking through the holes,
in the structure of the game!
That's not to give it any discredit!
Let's be honest! For those of you who know how many indie horror games that I've played in the past,
I've played way worse than this.
And I'm not even saying this is too bad, it just could use a little more polish and something a little more interesting.
Than a box-like maze.
But still! It got me.
So thank you everybody so much for watching!
If you want to see more of this, you can check out the link in the description below.
*loud screaming* HEY WOAH HEY BUDDY!
He heard I was talking shit about him!
So, you can see more of it as he nibbles my jibblets into destruction,
And, thank you everybody so much for watching!
If you wanna see some of these older indie horror games that I've played,
There's a big ol' playlist with over 200 videos!
Of scary games that I've played in the plast. [past]
Pluh!
So, check that out in the description
and, thank you everybody so much for watching.
And as always! I will see you...
In the next video! *sexy stare*
Buh-bye!